before I get started I should tell you a
little bit about myself and co-op
researcher here at Bloomberg well in New
York City at Bloomberg and I also an
adjunct faculty at Columbia University
and NYU and as an open source developer
I mostly work on Jupiter in the area of
interactive widgets and on a lower local
continent called triplets
can you understand my American Heights
French seams you can so I think that
pretty much everyone here knows about
Jupiter and which is a set of tools to
improve the workflow of scientist in
scientific computing and the tip of the
iceberg in the Jupiter ecosystem is the
Jupiter notebook which is a web-based
interactive environment for computing
although there is a code by Richard
Hamming saying that computing is more
about insight than numbers and as
scientists most of the time when you're
using a wrapper or console or a notebook
you are looking for insight and you are
not building a complicated system based
that would be already be specified you
are trying to find answers to your
questions and this is where the notebook
and especially in Turkey we just are
really useful so the work that I'm
presenting here is not just my work
itself which it is a work of a lot of
people so every time I present a new
component I will put on the pictures of
a few of the people some of the main
people involved in each project so the
first project I want to talk about is
the foundational layer for interactive
widgets in the Jupiter notebook it's
called I buy widgets and if you want to
install it right now the latest version
is available as a count a package in the
counter for channel so you can count
down install - the Condor Forge I buy
wood so
sure I can iPad widgets' so what you
need to do is counter install - the
counter Forge I buy widgets so everybody
knows about it
Jupiter in the book and it's a really
nice environment to perform interactive
computing and also nice replacement for
the council where you can type a simple
typing instruction and get the output
printing below like print four times
four and last time I checked still 16
and if you actually are want to study or
go further into the study of the school
function you can add it again the cell
hit print
seven times seven and get the expected
answer if you want to be a little bit
more efficient you can write a fraction
and call the function with different
inputs but as you see every time I
change the code it I get pretty much
instantaneous response and in that loop
here which is you typing the code in the
strip in a notebook hitting execute
getting a response from the kernel and
displaying the output the bottleneck is
you and it's not the rest of the group
and the point of widget is to try to
reduce that bottleneck here so what you
could do for example to reduce them that
the time that you need to enter a new
input into this really eval print loop
so for example what you can do is
declare slider and a slider is in this
context a patent object and when you ask
the ipython notebooks Drupal a notebook
to display the slider it will provide
you with a small interactive GUI
component in line in the notebook that
is the visual representation of that
slider so you can ask for the current
value of the slider from the bottom of
your Python code or modify the value
where the minimum was five so it's being
flowed by 2 by 5 but you can
- biting really from Peyton and now what
I'm doing is linking a float text widget
with a slider and displaying the output
of the link between the study of the
text in the inner in the text area now
if I want again to explore the square
function rather than basically linking
the values I can add a transformation
callback to the link object and this
time what I'm going to see is the result
of the square function which is actually
really accelerating that part I mean the
left-hand side of the of the read eval
print loop here so there is another way
to do the same thing which is - so we
can also display another view of the
same widget so there is another way to
do the same thing which is to use the
interact API so interact is a function
of aitai widgets that uses the
introspection features of the of the
Python programming language two weeks to
try to extract information about the
function that you pass to it and build
automatically agree for to help you
explore that function so here if I type
interact F where F would be the square
function right away it knows from the
default value of the X arguments that I
put data provide that it should use a
slider since it's a it is a number and I
will see the output of the square
function over that range or I can use
slightly more I would say complicated
abbreviation for that slider which is a
triple defining the min and the max
value and this time I have a more like a
wider range or instead of using
aberration I can completely specify the
widget that I should use for interacting
with the X parameter so in this case I
just asked for X to be an insulator with
a mean being equal to zero Max being
500 and with a step of two and there you
go so interact actually is allows you to
use the introspection features with more
complicated functions so in that case I
have a function that takes string and
number a boolean and a double so each
one of these actually would be
aggravations for a type of widget that
should be used to interact with that
parameter so what I'm what I'm getting
here is a automatically generated we
where I can change the title of the
chart instead of revenue is going to be
a profit modify one of the input
parameters of the displayed function and
or change the code change the color of
the line so what's really happening here
is that each one of these widgets that
I've been displaying here in line is
actually a synchronized object so it is
an object on the right-hand side and
also has a counterpart model object on
the JavaScript side and every time I
asked a notebook to display in line I'll
get a new view of that widget displayed
for in onion in the notebook or in a
different layout so every time there is
a change of model attribute on the
right-hand side it gets reflected in the
on the JavaScript side and the views
will change their appearance accordingly
every time I move the slider value and
the JavaScript side the this event will
trigger a model change in the JavaScript
model and which will be reflected and
synchronized with the patent so besides
the slider and if you drop down and
other text area widgets that you've seen
the cool I patent widgets library has a
bunch of other components such as image
HTML ranch Tyler's label etc
so but more importantly it's not only a
small set of widget it is also a
framework upon which you can build to
make your own interactive widgets based
on third party or custom JavaScript
libraries to display more complicated
things in line in the notebook so now
I'm going to move on and show you Vikki
blood and Vicky's blood is actually a
lightweight protein library that is
built upon I by widgets that was
developed by a quantum at Bloomberg and
so provided some of the pictures of the
authors here it's a virtual licensed and
what the couplet provides a high-level
plotting procedures for with relevant
defaults for the common chart types such
as histogram line chart heat map etc a
boss and also a lower level descriptions
of data visualizations meant for complex
interactive visualizations dashboards
and applications that would involve user
interactions where you could use charts
in the same way you use ladders as an
input widgets for older computation so
if you want to try the plot right now
it's also available as a count a package
and converted counterforce
so what you can do is kinda install -
the condor forge miki plot and
everything should work Python 3 as well
yeah this notebook is patent - but yeah
23 so here's a quick simple example
where in public blood generated some
data and I simply call plot with a link
space for X and some other values for Y
and options for the axis and you get
what you should expect from any regular
protein library which is an in line plot
in the Jupiter notebook but unlike the
current state of method [ __ ] this plot
is fully interactive on the JavaScript
side so for example you can zoom in and
zoom out or download
image as a PNG or reset the current zoom
and pan and zoom attributes to the
earlier values so for now there's
nothing really original here it's just a
regular operating library that has a
bunch of high-level routines to create
scatter plots line charts histograms
maps and many others but it's pretty
it's pretty solid but more interestingly
actually these are just high-level
functions that tap into a lower level
API that you can use to build more
complicated visualizations what what
actually happens here is that every
single item on this chart is an
independent widget that is a subject
that you synchronized between the back
end and the front end so the scatterer
here the access the color bar are
independent widgets so for example here
I can build a visualization by just
assembling my visualization uses of
these objects so the core idea of the
couplet is that we are following a
recommendation for plotting libraries
called the grammar of graphics that is
led by Whittington that is a set of
recommendations about the architecture
of how blogging should be done and one
of the the main I would say core object
in the grammar of graphics is the notion
of scale a scale is actually a mapping
between a data and a visual quantity it
could be pixels colors size of a marker
and a scatter plot and the data could be
numbers categorical data so as you build
your visualization you are going to
create these mappings between your data
types and the visual attributes so what
I'm doing in this example here is I'm
creating one ordinal scale and two
linear scales and a few access access
being visual representations of scales
and finally the marks which are the
items or beliefs that I put in the blood
so I create a few scales
and a few a few marks and finally my
figure is just the collection of access
marks and some top-level options for my
figures such as were should I display
the legend and there you go
which which makes makes it really
interesting here is that I can
dynamically change attributes of these
objects and see the entire figure
reflect those changes for example in
that case I can just change the data for
the X data the Y data for this line
chart and see that the figure update
every time I change the data or what you
can also do is yeah same here for the
for a scatter plot that updates every
time I change the x and y so the same
holds for the attributes of scale access
legends any sort of label that you may
have in the chart so here for example I
change the minimum value of the X scale
to 4 so that it's not computing
completely from the data anymore but
it's active actually pin to 4 if I set
it back to none what I'm getting is the
original chart that was where the ranges
were completed based on the data
Valon yes you can
yeah we have scales for for geographical
projections to two dimensional scale
security so
moreover Vicky's blood is not just a
standalone library it's very easy to
bind it with other widgets of the
college's library so you can wire bigger
blood widgets with other Jupiter widgets
so in this example for example I created
a scatter scatter plot and a slider and
moving the slider is going to allow me
to change the rotation attribute of the
markers live and I don't really have to
know any JavaScript to do this type of -
to do these type of things so you can
also use BQ plot
years as input widgets so for example
you can make selections in a data set by
just creating a selector on the on the
chart so this one set a cursor is
actually interesting it's an interval
selector were the center of the interval
corresponds to the original position of
my the mouse and the width of the
interval is actually linked to the
height of the to the vertical position
of the of the of the most mentor pointer
in the chart so it's actually faster to
change the interval that is selected
with such an interval selector than with
a like a regular brush selector because
where you would have to click multiple
times to move the right hand side of the
left hand side so that you can easily
storm through the data and perform an
analysis on a specific subset without
having to click multiple times and of
course the selected attributes of the
line is a natural beauty that you
synchronize with the pattern that you
can react to with callbacks etc or you
can also draw on jobs and in my yeah for
in this I remove the selector and use
the hand raw interaction and now I can
actually draw and change the data of my
figures so if I have any sort of
computation that requires that takes
some function as an input you can easily
you know just draw the function and see
what would be the outcome of your
computation for that function it's very
very easy to do on same thing if you
want to tamper with data you can easily
take a point in the scatterplot
move it move it around and see what
actually study would be the impact here
for example you see that the mean
horizontal line is is actually changing
as I move the points so that
yeah everything is synchronized in with
the Python side and rather than
computing the mean it can be some more
complicated analysis like PCA and also
you can very easily test the sensitivity
to a given point by just moving the
point which is yeah it's also reactive
you can have a callback that is on the
bottom side that is called so all of
this here for example here I made a very
simple one where I am computing the mean
on update line so I should zoom in and
I'm just saying that the value ended
value is the mean yeah the lines that Y
is NP that mean of scheduled at Y its
nervous at all line I don't know where
the question person who has a questions
yeah yeah you can it's always
synchronized every time you move and
every mouse move you get I mean you can
actually parameterize that you can
decide to actually only get the event
when you release the mouse if there is
too much computation done every time you
remove it so it's very it's very easy
actually to to so the goal here is again
to shorten that loop of interaction that
you have with the computation in that
you don't need to change the parameters
anymore manually you can just you know
do it graphically in the notebook and so
bigger block is really meant to remain
lightweight and to be more of an
interaction type of library than a
full-fledged blotting library that do
everything you want and the replacement
format party for example see them more
as input widgets than actual than the
library that you want to use if you want
to display two hundred thousand points
in the page it's not really the right
tool for this it's right or if you want
to build this sort of interacting
dashboard and applications where you can
move points and see other dancing lines
around reflecting those changes
so actually we had some people who had
never written any biting code or
JavaScript in the past and it could be
rolled as the first program amazing
dashboards where you have these sort of
interactions so it's actually fairly
easy to use now I want you to talk about
another package called the PI 3GS which
was studied by Jason grad who is now
also at Bloomberg and a couple of
students office and I'm now also
contributing to it and packages is
another custom widget library that is a
Jupiter widget wrapper around 3GS and if
you have never heard of UJ s UJ s is a
3d scene description library for the
browser so let me give you a quick
example here so in this example I
divided I just am plotting a college
here and I have a point that he is a
picture on my surface whenever I double
click I would add a new point on the on
the original surface I can rotate zoom
it's pretty fluid and the way I describe
this from the right hand side is truly
by describing the entire scene from the
camera position where the lights come
from what are the objects in the scene
and I get this sort of output as a
interactive widgets and again every one
of these items can be synchronized with
a byte inside and the result of
computation so this one example here was
just a surface plot I can also change
the height dynamically and you will see
this reflected in the widget so quick
example here so in this example I had to
make a concession which was to write
some JavaScript in line for the object
that I'm going to to display and for
example here I'm just displaying some
biometric surface which I can rotate and
zoom in so I by which I PI so by 3GS is
a custom we just library built upon I
buy widgets
and therefore is very easily
interoperable without like widgets so
you can link attributes of the by Fugees
objects with regular sliders and other
core widgets of the lab I would just
library so in this example for example I
am linked some attributes of the camera
position with three sliders and I have
also also a more complex parametric
shape that is parameterize with three
attributes XYZ that I can change
dynamically and observe the result live
in my 3d shape that I am exploring so so
to respond to your earlier question
actually on the right hand side I am
changing the camera position every time
there is a mouse move and in this case
I'm only computing things when I release
the the slider and the third so if you
want to install back by 3GS before I
move on you can easily do this again the
latest version is available in Canada
Forge so you can do Canada install
Dashti can't afford refugees and you get
this version and this notebook should
run flawlessly
now leaflet leaflet is the third custom
widgets library that we released last
week it is a wrapper around the
well-known leaflet JavaScript library
for mapping it was originally offered by
offered by Brian Grainger and I sort of
revived it some time ago to make it work
with a new widget infrastructure and so
it makes it really easy to create
interactive maps in the notebook so in
this example I'm just setting the
coordinates where that I want to see and
I have a simple map in line but you can
also draw on it add items dynamically
from the Python side and
we take this example where I take some
data that is in the Geo JSON format that
I'm just adding to the map dynamically
from the pipe inside so yeah leaflet is
a really popular and poor for okay it's
a really popular on poor for JavaScript
library that has been used in many areas
and has lots of contributors and by just
enabling people to create wrapper
widgets on the top of a pie widget you
can bring the power of all the
JavaScript ecosystem into the Jupiter
notebook and you don't really really
don't have to know much to to do this
for example there is a couple of weeks
ago I on a couple of other ones from
Bloomberg participated in a hackathon in
San Francisco and we built a nice
application using interactive widgets
that I wanted to to show here where we
actually have a combination of Vicky
plot and a code path heat map and
whenever you hover your mouse on a zip
code in San Francisco you would see a
number of features of that neighborhood
and cross this pane on the right hand
side and which are completely
dynamically by your Python code and it's
a really non-trivial application to make
if you want to make it outside of the
Jupiter notebook and here you don't
really have to know any JavaScript to
build this so I have a couple of minutes
more so as I wanted to talk a bit more
about GIS so you can also use libraries
such as such as a GDL to interpret some
GIS data and here I downloaded some
terrain elevation data from the Grand
Canyon and the Grand Canyon which is
available freely online
displayed in packages so unfortunately
here I didn't really adjust the camera
position in advance and it doesn't
really look like the Grand Canyon and if
I want you to adjust the camera position
what I could could do is change it
dynamically from the patent code and
have a better perspective on the Grand
Canyon elevation data although if I
modify it again from the right-hand side
it's you know it's going it's quite a
slow process so what we want to do is
again accelerate that loop here between
where the bottleneck is you typing the
code in the saw so stylers are nice but
they're the only bring you so find that
you can only modify one value at a time
so which is rather painful still so it
happens that the browser has an API for
game controllers so as part of the coop
I would just library we actually
integrated the this report to embroider
to the jupiter notebook so what you can
do is create declared controller so pad
is equal to i pi will just dot
controller and display the controller
widget and what I'm being asked to do is
to connect a gamepad and press any
buttons which I'm going to do here I
brought my xbox 360 controller with me I
plug it press the button and here have
an inline view of my gamepad and as I'm
moving the axis and buttons see the
states in line in the notebook right and
this is part of the coop I will just
average not personal average really
quote web by widgets I can interact with
those values from the Python code and
read them or react to their changes
dynamically with Python callback so what
I did here is that I decided to bind the
values of the of the access to the
camera position and what I get is a
twenty nine spicy noodle for Jupiter in
the book so which I find is pretty cool
I don't think we can do anything shorter
than that since I have a couple of more
minutes I want you to talk a bit about
the future and so which is a very close
future it's almost a present so the
future of Jupiter is so one of the
things that will happen the future for
the of Jupiter which is written very
bright is Jupiter lab were instead of
having a single page where you must Lee
have a notebook we want to enhance the
experience to that of a full-fledged
desktop application where you could have
a text editor console in the spirit of
the QT console a notebook FedEx for all
that in a single page instead of having
new tabs open for you in your browser
every time you open a notebook and with
a also like more I would say flexible
layout manager for 200 panes and
different parts of plugins of the
application so what about widgets so we
recently made the major release of
widget and one of the main changes there
is that we completely separated the
JavaScript side of the interactive
Python widgets into library called rivet
ojs widgets that is going that is a
stabilization of the JavaScript API that
should facilitate the work of kernel
authors to have to implement support for
other languages so for interactive
Jupiter widgets in our Giulia Haskell
and so the next items that we have that
we are working on for the hue next weeks
are the integration into Jupiter lab and
the deployment as standalone apps of
interactive widgets and so a couple of
days ago our so started working on a
cookie cutter template for people who
want to offer new custom widget
libraries by wrapping existing
JavaScript libraries which is available
on github so under the Jupiter or which
is
bootjet example yeah by the way if you
really like any of those visualizations
for example should restore the crown or
here what you can do now which is one of
the new features of the of the API is
that you can decide to embed interactive
widgets and you get a copy paste a bore
snippet of code that you can embed into
any HTML page and it will support custom
widget libraries like leaky blood I PI
leaflet PI 3GS and if you follow our
template for custom widget libraries
like the cookie cutter I was talking
about earlier
then you will have all of this for free
so now you can easily build an
application in the Jupiter netbook and
once you like it you deploy and you have
a standalone app running in the web
browser so yeah that's it
thank you are there any questions thank
you for the presentation we're good I
wanted to ask what are your thoughts on
bouquet and are you thinking of merging
your efforts or way yeah we were
discussing this just yesterday with a
main of your bouquet I think there are
areas were referred sort of converge in
that currently bouquet uses a different
way of being displayed in line in the
notebook and it could rely on the widget
infrastructure for this another area of
convergence could you have the book a
server also which could be helpful yeah
so the bouquet server is sort of yeah
unrelated to Jupiter I would say and
there is also on in a bucket properties
and thread let's are two ways of
implementing the same thing and maybe we
could try to make them either make them
more compatible or transparent for the
user to use one
other and make them work together so
this is another area where could work
together
hi I'm great presentation and when you
moved in around of the X Box can you
also drag it with the mouse as well
interactively which back with when you
use the Xbox controller yeah to move
around the map can you also drag it with
the mouse as well yeah you could have
also a mouse controller for the camera
and yeah okay you could do boy smus a
great presentation again a collection
regarding bouquet and also blood Lee I
mean as a not so frequent user of
graphics I'm slightly confused that
there is now another way another library
available so which one would you
recommend for which applications and
what's the difference and you know do we
have to really learn all three of them
so I would say that
so there's Matt Berkeley this book is
likely there is that about Berkeley I
don't know much about it except that it
exists so I can't really tell you much
about it
it's GPL this is my understanding so if
you want to use in a corporate context
might be an issue and between bouquet
outside that bouquet is much more
large-scale project and BQ plot PQ plot
is really meant to be a like lightweight
custom widget library and you know that
lives in that world of were you of you
know coastal mu Jets such as by Fuji as
I Peggy flat and bokeh is its own
framework it has also interactive
widgets and yeah so yeah there there is
there is duplication there but a
floodlit with Claude Lee I mean so yeah
MATLAB is a different list in that a lot
of the rendering logic I mean most of it
or all of it is done the backend so if
you want to have any sort of interaction
in the in the context of a web
application if there is any so any
latency with the backend you I mean it's
not going to work very well so I would
say that MATLAB is still the best or if
you want to have publication quality
charts for your paper that is not meant
for dashboarding
web application building or anything
like this
yeah great presentation once again thank
you
my question is about I PI widgets so
which is ipython we just have evolved
from you know from ipython Jupiter
now it's a separate repo they have a
number of bugs so it's been quite
painful to you know keep up with them so
do you know if they're now in a sort of
stable state and another kind of
follow-up questions of what you shown
like the Jupiter lab is awesome I mean
because that's what I think a lot of
people want to be able to publish like
on the web the notebook so what's the
roadmap for that project as well so for
for the widgets first they were sort of
an experimental thing for a long time I
would say the legacy in the book in
there in the book and in the server
Network has and Jupiter in general has
gone through what we call the big spread
which is the two separated this massive
modern monolithic project into multiple
and more modular projects that could
evolve independently and lately I buy
widgets has gone through the same thing
now there is a bite inside that he's
independent of the JavaScript library
which is for the first time sort of I
would say stabilized in that we have a
proper NPM package that has will follow
semver for the versioning and so we will
document a breakage of the API so it
should be more stable and easier to
follow changes there in a diverges
Jupiter lab is a complete revamp of the
front-end of Jupiter so if you have
custom extensions for the notebook you
will have to work to do some work to
make it work with Jupiter lab although
the
widgets themselves and especially the
current branch master are meant to work
in both the old notebook and Jupiter lab
so in soon you will have beer with the I
mean you will be able to do things such
as have all the workflows where you have
a console like a console cat kind of
input area and the single output area
will display all your widgets a bit like
shiny for all so yeah so widgets is an
area that should have compatibility we
should have compatibility between the or
notebook and the new notebook manage
security also with multiple users it's
more of a network state again quite hear
the second part because you have you
managed to set up Jupiter with multiple
users integrating with Active Directory
yeah
I'm pretty not the right person to
answer that but I could say that another
main feature of Jupiter is a arbitrary
code exists so it's a feature so if you
want to have multiple users you probably
need to have some sort of isolation by
VMs or docker instances and so which is
pretty much the area of another project
in the Jupiter or which is called crypto
hub which has utilities to do that so
widgets especially custom widgets are
arbitrary code execution in the front
end if you are low custom widgets you
could have a whitelist of a load widget
and yeah this is another we could take
this offline and discuss adapter yeah I
just had a question about how closely a
couple a lot of the widgets to Jupiter
so if I wanted to run them off
of my favorite IDE which which you know
and I know didn't want to put it in a
tabular format with that a so if your
IDE can connect to a channel
especially with the new jupiter lab
thing that we are building you will be
able to interact with that journal and
have them displayed elsewhere so that
you like in a browser window or
something like this and we have been
working how to decouple it from the
notebook and that feature that I was
showing in the end where you can just
embed widgets and put it into any
webpage is in the part of this in that
it doesn't really depend on the notebook
JavaScript anymore okay thanks a lot you
have a question about the Jupiter lamp
do you have a time scale when that's
likely to be available at least for as a
beta that people can play around with um
no okay thank you